Pixar just released the next sneak peek
at Incredibles 2 and hidden in the new
footage of some cool details on Easter
eggs you might have missed
yippee k movie lovers it's Jan here and
today I'm delving into the new
Incredibles 2 trailer for Pixar Easter
egg superhero references and a possible
villain we haven't yet met if you're new
here I do lots of Pixar and superhero
movie videos so subscribe to my channel
to get everything as soon as I post it
plus I've got a new Pixar giveaway for
all my subscribers later in this video
superheroes are illegal we're not saying
you have what if like mr. incredible
you're wondering where this line came
from well it seems to be a cool
reference to Batman Begins it's not who
I am underneath but what I do
it defines me I left the Pixar obviously
continuing to have fun with superhero
law and putting their own spin on lines
from Christopher Nolan's Batman trilogy
also in this scene is a regular but less
well-known Pixar Easter egg which is a
very specific Chinese takeout container
design this same style of food box has
appeared four times previously in Pixar
movies the first time was in a bug's
life where it was called the Chinese
cabinet of metamorphosis by mani who
used it for a circus act the most
mysterious regions of Uncharted easier I
give you the Chinese cabinet of Newsies
other places it's appeared in Pixar
movies include in the Pizza Planet truck
in Toy Story 2 in Linguini's apartment
in ratatouille and most recently an
inside out were like The Incredibles
family Riley and her family also sat
down for a dinner of Chinese takeout
help me bring Super's back into the
sunlight
Elastigirl no problem okay so here we
get our first look at Winston Dever and
his deaf tech organization and he's
making it clear he wants to hire a lass
t girl for his own missions now if we
jump back a moment to this shot at the
Municipal Airport there's a nasty girl
arriving on her motorbike but look
really carefully and you'll notice
there's another figure standing next to
Winston Dever I wonder if that could be
his sister Evelyn who you can gather
from her name Evelyn Dever or perhaps
pronounced evil endeavour sounds like
she's probably going to have a
villainous role in the movie we also get
to see that Elastigirl has been kitted
out with a new slick outfit as well as a
motorbike and they both have an
interesting new logo which looks like
the letters E and G of Elastigirl have
been combined I notice that the
waterfalls at Elastigirl drives out of
is a callback to syndrome's l'abbé
waterfall which also worked as a hidden
opening in the first Incredibles movie
on the surface the maths joke seems it's
probably a jab at the u.s. Common Core
math standard and the criticism it's
come under from parents I don't know
that way why would they change math
however given the book - holds up his
cool new math for life this might
actually also be a reference to the new
math syllabus which was introduced in
the 1960s in the US and some European
countries as an attempt to improve
mathematical skills and interest in
science during the Cold War
additionally this fits in with a 60s
esque setting of The Incredibles movies
we also get a glimpse of Jack Jack
literally turning into a little monster
again as he did when he defended himself
against Syndrome at the end of the first
film
the trainer's cut together pretty
quickly but it looks like Jack Jack gets
a specific power when he's angry and it
seems here it's because mr. incredible
won't give him any more cookies it was
great to see Edna mode back and judging
by the look of mr. incredible I think
he'll be turning to her for help after
becoming exhausted trying to look after
Jack Jack as she did for Elastigirl in
the first movie I'm sure this time
she'll be offering him some of her
signature brand of advice you're talking
about and I wonder if she'll also be
designing him or Jack Jack a new costume
but no capes of course darling
something classic like Dyna guy oh here
look the cape and the boots no caps so
were there any other things you spotted
or enjoyed about the new Incredibles -
trailer and do you have any predictions
or theories about what Winston's ever
and his sister will be up to in the
sequel on this video I'm starting a
Pixar giveaway for an awesome art of
cocoa hardback book for all my
subscribers so get subscribing and
commenting about the trailer for a
chance to win if you like this and do
hit the thumbs up button and share the
video with your friends your support is
hugely appreciated and if you want to
get all my new Pixar in superhero videos
and tap the Bell and join the
notification squad coming next will be
my Black Panther videos plus a very
special cocoa video until then you can
check out more videos you might like
right here thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers